es ist nun wirklich still über allen
gipfeln in tirol
obwohl es hier boden im zillertal wohl
noch mehr als sonst im land
denn hier ist europas größter hotspot
der südafrika mutante die gondeln laufen
zwar das hat die seilbahn lobby
durchgesetzt aber die parkplätze sind
leer die hotels geschlossen so auch das
der familie stock in vier jahrzehnten
des bestehens ist in einer wintersaison
daniel stock hier noch nie so allein
gewesen statt 300 gästen lehre fast alle
180 mitarbeiter in kurzarbeit
tirol ist abgeriegelt von seinen
wichtigen deutschen gästen auch nach
österreich gibt es reisebeschränkungen
daniel stock gibt sich trotzdem
optimistisch man sei es gewohnt das
tiroler auf diese art an den pranger
gestellt würden sagt es sind diese die
eh alles für eine machen und das wissen
die gutgläubigen und die die herzlichen
mit denen geht mehr schneller vors
gericht dass wir mit einer großen macht
mit dem stocksteifen sozusagen david
gegen goliath tirol gegen wien das ist
dein land gepflegtes selbstbild nicht
erst seit dann tiroler grenzen die
österreichische armee steht wegen der
mutante verlangt die österreichische
regierung nun einen negativen test bei
ausfahrt denn das kleine werk volk wie
hätte sich erfolgreich dagegen selbst
maßnahmen zu verhängen und das klingt zu
jetzt ist der punkt kommen wo es reicht
eindeutig und das was jetzt passiert ist
wie er wieder klar auf die rollup
gezielt und das lassen uns immer
gefallen
die wiener reisewarnung südtirol so wie
wir in wien antriebsarmut deutschen und
die holländer die sind ja viel wichtiger
für uns
dann schließt auch deutschland die
grenzen zu tirol fast komplett ein
schock diese angriffe auf das schöne
tirol so mathis daniel stock hätten
nicht nur mit der angst vor der mutante
zu tun ein bisschen neid eifersucht ist
dabei aber wir behalten tirol ihr nicht
für uns wir ziehen ja keine mauern hoch
sondern wir wir empfangen
wir würden ja alle willkommen heißen die
mauern werden ja eben genau von denen
gesetzt von den wienern und von von
deutscher seite am vergangenen samstag
versammeln sich in innsbruck einige
hundert zur verteidigung tirols wie sie
sagen
die demo ist corona bedingt verboten die
polizei dass sie trotzdem gewähren
die wut ist groß auch auf die presse die
tiere zum einen sie als corona schleuder
hinstellt
[Musik]
ich bin immer schon patriot gewesen und
stehe für maler und tirol und die finde
es eine frechheit was jetzt aufgeführt
wird
aber das haben wir schon bringt dass sie
auch in summe das macht ins leere da
finde frechheit von hans oder weil die
sonst ja selber bei der nase nehmen weil
die ansteckungsgefahr geht von ihnen aus
weil der was dort das afrikanische zeigt
oberbruch dort das war deutscher bei der
kleineren genehmigten gegenkundgebung
ist david creed aktiv ist und künstler
die aufgeheizte atmosphäre in tirol
leger auch an der holter und den
rhetorik meint er
man merkt einfach wie sehr sprache
unsere wirklichkeit beeinflusst und auch
unsere vorstellungen blickwinkel einfach
auch steuert und eben der eskalation
wäre auf jeden fall angesagt
david reed ist schon vielen politikern
mit provokanten aktionen auf die füße
getreten
er kritisiert die überbordende bedeutung
des tourismus im land die enge
verflechtung von wirtschaft und politik
die tiroler verteidigungshaltung jetzt
erklärt also das ist ein damit zusammen
dass die rolle fällt zum zweiten mal
schon im internationalen fokus steht
weil das auftreten grad unserer
männlichen älter den weißen vp politiker
so bockig und budget und teilweise
beinlich war dass er viele denken so ja
wir werden jetzt nur mehr kritisiert nur
mehr angriffen jetzt müsse man gerade
extra unsere erde verteilten oder so
trotz burg tirol wirtschaftlich ist das
unmöglich deutsche sind auch in
kitzbühel sonst die wichtigsten gäste
deutschland der wichtigste exportmarkt
roland hebbel muss nun um liefertermine
fürchten weil deutsche grenzkontrollen
seine lkw mindestens bremsen die
haustechnik firma ist systemrelevant
deutsche mitarbeiter wie alexander noll
dürfen die grenze klären aber es nervt
[Musik]
katastrophen reformen anstoßen konnten
hier grenzschließungen ist der
schlechteste hilfsmittel was wir jetzt
derzeit handhaben
warum wir werden auch in zukunft
miteinander leben müssen und dieses
miteinander funktioniert mit
geschlossenen grenzen definitiv nicht
das bergvolk sei aber harte arbeit bei
widrigen umständen gewohnt erklärt apple
jetzt ist eben wieder so eine zeit mehr
mühen mehr videokonferenzen heißt das
für ihn hätte tirol mehr aus fehlern
lernen können
apple mag das wort ist nicht mehr in den
mund nehmen
das muss man irgendwann haben wir
vergessen können und nicht immer auf
sachen die vor einem in der
vergangenheit gewesen sind einfach immer
nur wieder drauf haken um dann irgendwo
wieder etwas negatives draufzusetzen
wir müssen vorausschauen und dieses
vorausschauen heißt auch vergangenheit
vergessen wer diese berge liebt wird es
wohl auch vergessen wollen
sosehr tirols ruf vielleicht gelitten
hat diese landschaft bleibt